[Musique]
où
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 18 juin
l'actualité c'est la fête de la musique
qui sera bien maintenu cette année
malgré la crise sanitaire
elle sera évidemment un peu particulière
avec un protocole renforcé dès ce
week-end des concerts dans les yvelines
sont prévues tout comme le jour j lundi
21 juin
nous découvrirons le portrait d'une
jeune chanteuse et nous ferons le point
avec nos invités
samuel strouk directeur artistique du
jazz festival de maisons laffitte et
gilles rodriguez régisseur studio à la
batterie à guyancourt
côté loisirs cette semaine avec célia
gâte sombres nous iront cueillir des
fraises à la ferme de gally de saint cyr
l'école et nous vous proposerons de
découvrir happy days la fête annuelle de
la bei à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
juste avant cela la ville d'elancourt a
commémoré ce vendredi à 11 heures devant
l'hôtel de ville
l'appel du 18 juin 1940 du général
charles de gaulle
le maire d'elancourt et président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a prononcé un discours puis il
a déposé plusieurs gerbes au pied de la
stèle à l'effigié du général de gaulle
on écoute jean michel fourgous
il faut maintenant qu on ait des
dirigeants qui ont prouvé leur valeur
ajoutée pour aller à un niveau supérieur
voilà ce que moi je demandé et le
général de gaulle je crois que lui il a
vraiment montré sa valeur ajoutée sa
prise de risque sont son
désintéressement etc des valeurs comme
ça on en a besoin bien une vision en
norme un garçon qu avec certainement une
intelligence une une compréhension des
enjeux mondiaux
c'est de cela dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui la france fait
comme je vous le disais en titre la fête
de la musique aura bien lieu ce lundi 21
juin malgré le contexte sanitaire
toutefois dès ce week end et concerts
sont prévus dans les yvelines amour
passé rose qu'on auteur compositeur
interprète qui se produira sur scène
elle présentera les titres de son ep qui
devrait sortir cette année
portrait de cette jeune artiste est
étudiante à lui exclu par astrid bergère
rose de son nom de scène à 22 ans elle
est auteur compositeur interprète mais
aussi étudiante en lettres modernes elle
a commencé la musique au début de son
adolescence comme un échappatoire à une
famille qui ne la rendait pas heureuse
chez moi les une fille ça se marie très
tôt et on ne demande pas forcément son
avis sur la politique sur les études sur
sa façon de s'habiller et pour moi la
musique c'était le seul ou même
l'écriture des paroles c'est le seul
moyen d'écrire ce que je voulais sans
m'en prendre une donc j'ai trouvé ça
génial je dirige et quand vous êtes face
à une feuille blanche pouvait raturé
vous pouvez écrire vous êtes la
maîtresse de la feuille blanche et moi
mais c'est tranquille quand je faisais
ça à ses 18 ans elle a quitté sa ville
natale strasbourg pour étudier dans les
yvelines
c'est ici qu'elle s'est engagé davantage
dans la musique quand je suis arrivé ici
je préfère tout et n'importe quoi mais
j'étais vraiment vraiment tout seul
c'était la jungle mais c'était la
première fois que je que je me sente
heureuse en fait j'ai fait des fêtes de
la musique j'ai participé à des concours
j'ai fait des balles je me suis déjà
inscrits pour chanter c'était dans un
petit village la moyenne des achats
s'étaient 65 ans c'était génial
rose ne se cantonne pas qu'à un style
ses influences viennent du brésil de la
russie ou encore de la chine elle va
bientôt sortir un ep après cette année
difficile d'un point de vue musical et
bien vous mettez pose sur surtout alors
que
il ya une certaine frustration qui monte
il ya des gens qui vous appelle et qui
vous disent final je te lâches et puis
il va en boîte vous recommencez
toulepleu début vous avez envie pleurer
mais là ça va mieux depuis depuis un
mois ça va beaucoup mieux ça reprend et
puis projet mon projet à moi sera
bientôt terminée donc en attendant de
rejoindre peut-être un label ou une
maison de disques elle appelle tous les
jours dans la salle de concert de
l'université versailles saint quentin
elle se produira pour la fête de la
musique le 19 juin à maurepas et le 21
juin à saint rémy les chevreuse
vous pourrez donc voir rosamor pas ce
week-end et pour continuer à parler de
cette fête de la musique qui a lieu ce
lundi 21 juin jour j traditionnel de la
fête de la musique mais aussi tout le
week-end dans les yvelines nous
accueillons avec nous samuel strouk et
guitariste compositeur et directeur
artistique au jazz festival de maisons
laffitte bonsoir bonsoir également avec
nous ils rodriguez régisseur studio est
chargé des enregistrements à la batterie
de guyancourt bonsoir bonsoir
alors d'abord gilles rodriguez qui a
t-il ou programme de la batterie pour
cette traditionnelle fête de la musique
et cette édition 2021 un peu
particulière oui au programme c'est donc
demain samedi 19 juin de 17h à 22h
nous avons quatre scènes à la batterie
avait que cinq entre cinq et six groupes
sur chaque scène est un programme
musical très éclectique comme d'habitude
du rock des ensembles de l'école de
musique du jazz du reggae de la world
music
voilà très éclectique elle a pour tous
les goûts donc on l'a bien compris et de
votre côté samuel strouk ce sera à
l'ouverture aussi un petit peu du jazz
festival de maisons laffitte qu'est ce
qui est prévu à goutte est complètement
la fête de la musique a été l'occasion
cette année d'ouvrir complètement le
festival qui commence le 21 juin à
l'occasion de la fête de la musique
alors été enlevée que c'est une fac de
la musique un peu particulière cette
année parce que tout le monde a reçu un
petit peu à ce qui se passe en termes de
préconisations comptage de mesures
sanitaires à respecter etc
on a prévu de faire un concert dans le
square de la le square balzer ben je
crois que la salle malesherbes et son
lafitte à partir de 20h30 jusqu'à 22h30
nous accueillerons une fanfare qui
s'appelle le gros tube pour 2,7 de
musique plutôt fanfare funk ragga funk
afro c'est vraiment du gros son des
fanfares
parce que pour nous quelque part à
l'esprit de la fête de la musique pour
cette ouverture c'était d'essayer de
voilà retrouver cette liberté on peut
sortir quand on a ses souvenirs de fêtes
de la musique autre fois où tout le
monde jouait dans la rue etc
à la fin vous a paru l'aspect le plus le
plus simple et plus entre idées mes
délires plus marrant pour convoquer les
gens donc attention le nombre de places
sera limité puisque on est tenu de gérer
les flux ivre le nombre de personnes sur
place
on fera tourner 300 personnes par 300
personnes sur place ne pourra pas faire
plus c'est à dire les règles salutaire
les gens seront vers le public sera
amené à être distancié et basques
également pour pour assister à cette
fanfare alors vous l'avez évoqué samuel
strouk donc des mesures un protocole
sanitaire renforcée dû au contexte
sanitaire qu'on connaît tous très bien
comment s'est passée justement
l'organisation pour définir ces jauges
dons qui sont aussi les règles de l'état
mais comment vous ça s'est passé à la
batterie pour pouvoir ou à
maisons-laffitte par deux coups au jazz
festival pour pouvoir définir tout ça
écoutez ça c'est pas plus compliqué nous
avions fait déjà un festival digital
l'an dernier au mois de mai juste sorti
du premier confirmant la sortie de
confinement on a tout de suite pris les
protocoles de déconfinement experts à
toutes les règles édictées par le
gouvernement
donc c'est assez simple on définit la
capacité d'un lieu on lui on lui
attribue un coefficient qui venait par
le gouvernement et certains dom
naturellement voilà le nombre de
placements peut avoir après
l'organisation était un petit peu
difficile cette année pas difficile mais
on va dire avec plus dangereux plus de
challenge parce que les informations
sont arrivés très tard et nous ne
savions pas jusqu'à on à dire pas avril
début mai ou est-ce que de l'allemand à
l'est et donc ça c'est vrai que pour un
festival de l'emploi de maisons de là ce
festival c'était une difficulté
supplémentaire étant donné que
habituellement on est prêt à partir de
janvier a déployé à dérouler la
communication etc ou clark vraiment
vraiment sollicité beaucoup les équipes
mais on est ravi
et si je veux dire un message c'est que
toutes les équipes n'attend plus qu'une
chose aujourd'hui c'est d'accueillir les
artistes d'accueillir le public et de
pouvoir enfin retrouver ses banques
partagent ces moments d'émotion ensemble
on se retrouve autour d'une proposition
artistique mais aussi autour d'une
ambiance familiale comme on essaye de le
proposer à maisons-laffitte quoi
l'autre côté gilles rodrigues j'imagine
que vous avez le même sentiment cette
organisation un peu particulière entre
mesures sanitaires et tout ça à
respecter pour quand même profiter de
ces festivités comment ça s'est passé de
votre côté à la batterie je dirai la
même chose ça c'est plutôt ça c'est
plutôt bien
il ya passé afin de s'adapter un petit
peu au dernier moment mais on a des nous
avons des équipes solides technicien
solide et voilà comme l'a dit samuel
avec des jauges limitées donc tout et
les concerts sans facile évidemment bien
évidemment masqué donc je crois qu'on
est à 65% de jauge de chaque lieu voilà
nous avons deux scènes extérieures
en espérant que la météo soit de la
partie et la salle de concert et
l'auditorium mais tout s'est
relativement bien passé on s'est adapté
oui l'adaptation c'est le maître mot un
petit peu depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire
alors la fête de la musique ça ouvre
aussi les festivités pour tout l'été
comment ça va se passer quels sont les
festivités programmées à la batterie de
guyancourt cette année alors la batterie
uniquement demain samedi 19 juin en
revanche jusqu'au 28 août
il ya des festivités dans tout ça file
dans tous les quartiers
beaucoup d'ateliers des concerts je peux
pas vous donner de programme précis
parce que il est vraiment conséquent
voilà ça commence demain ça commence dès
demain matin 10 heures dans le quartier
des soldes la batterie nos la batterie
c'est uniquement de de demain samedi 19
voilà sinon ça se prolonge dans toute la
ville en a pour tous les goûts des
ateliers de danse eu des concerts des
manifestations sportives dans tous les
quartiers de villes de guyancourt le
côté samuel strouk après ce jazz
festival quel est votre programme vous
vous êtes aussi guitariste compositeur
quel va être votre programme pour cet
été ecoutez-vous dordé pour programme
personnel défend je crois écoutez nous
l'a fait
musique ou vraiment que les festivités
c'est vraiment local de dire le
lendemain le mardi nous avons la
projection d'une version remasterisée au
cinéma l'atalante à maisons-laffitte du
film de lynne vanders bonne à vista
social club histoire de renouer avec la
fraternité la chaleur humaine cuba vont
se faire plaisir après toute cette
période d'enfermement et à partir de
mercredi 23 12 ouvrons en réalité ce
qu'on appelle les concerts in c'est à
dire les programmations à la fiche par
un concert retransmis en direct sur tsf
jazz mercredi 23 ces deux quintettes des
frères belmondo
nous enchaînons le lendemain avec une
soirée en partenariat avec le centre
dramatique national de sartrouville nous
accueillons une soirée entière dédiée au
jazz et au mélange du jazz avec le
moyen-orient
macha garrigues ans arabe est aussi l'un
des trompettistes mansonnien le plus
connu en france qui s'appelle sylvain
vantard qui jouera en duo avec dominique
fillon à 19 heures le 24 le 25 la
fameuse rhoda scott et son quartet
relais 10 apporte est entièrement
redistribuées de deux musiciens féminin
musicienne saxophone sophie alour de
gnac albero julie saury à la batterie et
rhoda scott et enfin nous avons le
samedi avant d'amener le festival le
dimanche nous aurons sabine création
mondiale avec qui réunira biréli lagrène
andré ceccarelli diego imbert il
orchestre national d'île de france
cette soirée sera filmé pour france tv
culture pour mezzo et je crois que le
programme sera redistribué aussi partie
des 78 il me semble et enfin nous
terminerons le festival sous l'angle du
swing des années 30 par le collectif
paris swing et enfin la voix soul de
emma lamadji three rivers quartet donc
ça fait un programme très éclectique
aussi avec les normands d'artistes qui
viennent de différents bords un temps
fort le 26 qui est déjà bien bien
remplie moi je suggère à tous ceux qui
nous regardent de ne pas tarder à
prendre leur place et parvenait et il
l'a bien compris merci samuel strouk
merci gilles rodrigues d'avoir été avec
nous pour toutes ces précisions pour ce
cette fuite week-end et on vous souhaite
que la fête de la musique soit la plus
belle possible
et dans le reste justement des
festivités pour cette fête de la musique
2021 vous voyez s'afficher sur votre
écran quelques idées de sorties autres
pour ce week-end dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines alors à magny
les hameaux attrape mais aussi encore à
coignières le tout évidemment dans le
respect des gestes barrières et
sanitaires contre la crise sanitaire et
après une semaine bien chargée quoi de
mieux que de se détendre le week-end en
plus de la fête de la musique
comme chaque vendredi s'il ya gars
tsongo vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
cette semaine nous allons vous présenter
des jeux ludo-éducatifs créé par une
habitante du mesnil-le-roi sais je
provoque un réel engouement auprès des
enfants parents enseignants mais aussi
du personnel paramédical pour répondre à
la demande la méline wav a lancé une
campagne de financement participatif
dont le montant des collectes permettra
d'acheter de nouvelles machines de
production
le montage de lucas ou bars dans son
atelier au mesnil-le-roi la gérante de
l'entreprise maza francs créé depuis
2015 des jeux éducatifs en bois depuis
l'automne 2020 elle a lancé cette
tablette ludique pour l'apprentissage de
l'écriture
l'idée c'est de pouvoir accompagner
l'enfant dans le dessein de la lèvre sur
les tablettes est indiqué le ductus qui
est le sens de l'écriture et qui
facilite une écriture plus fluide et
plus rapide
ça permet aussi aux enfants qui peuvent
être porteurs de handicap ou qui ont des
déficits moteurs justement de travailler
la gestuelle travail le poignet parce
qu'en fait ça travaille le poignet ça
travaille la précision cette tablette a
connu depuis quelques mois un franc
succès d'abord auprès des parents puis
des enseignants et du personnel
paramédical
j'ai travaillé au départ sur cette
tablette des minuscules cursive et petit
à petit les enseignants les parents
m'ont dit mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire là aussi la tablette des
majestueux est ce que vous pouvez faire
les chiffres il est vraiment vu qu'il y
avait un vrai même besoin d'outils
d'outils pour accompagner les enfants
les élèves dans la mémorisation des
gestes de l'écriture apprendre à prendre
tout simplement à travailler la
motricité avec cet engouement annula
breton a décidé de s'agrandir
elle a trouvé un nouvel atelier plus
grand à maisons laffitte
il lui manque seulement de nouvelles
machines plus performantes
elle a donc lancé une campagne de
financement participatif sur hull
il me manque dix mille euros pour
compléter le financement
et ce qui me permettrait de passer
commande de machines cette campagne
ulule
effectivement c'est une collecte mais en
contrepartie vous achetez quelque part
vous précommandez la nouvelle édition
des tablettes d'écriture grâce à cet
argent la gérante va pouvoir développer
également de nouveaux supports de
motricité pour l'instant 4800 euros ont
déjà été récoltés la campagne de
financement s'arrêtera le 8 juillet si
vous aimez les fraises la cueillette de
ces fruits rouges a commencé aux fermes
de gally à saint-cyr-l'ecole que ce soit
pour des confitures des colis ou
simplement pour le dessert du soir les
clients peuvent venir remplir leurs
barquettes en semaine mais aussi le
week-end
bérengère bourgois en accueil pour nous
pour les cueillir on les ramasse par le
pédoncule par la queue contre attaque
pour éviter de deux marques est le fruit
de ses rétros le fruit et puis après il
suffit de croquer dedans avec une
quinzaine de jours de retard à cause de
la météo des mois d'avril et de mai la
saison des fraises est enfin arrivé
le principe de l'accueil de gally est
très simple
un espace qui est en accès libre c'est à
dire que les gens arrivent ils se garent
sur notre parking et un grand panneau
qui présente toutes les productions du
moment qui sont à maturité avec le prix
de chaque production puis après les gens
viennent ne soit ils prennent une
brouette qu'on met à leur disposition à
l'antre-2 en entrée du lieu oui j'aime
avec leurs cabas une dizaine de variétés
de fraises sont cultivés à galilée
fraisiers sont plantés soit en hauteur
sur des gouttières soit directement au
sol le but limiter les traitements en
limitant le contact aux mauvaises herbes
vous voyez ces phrases là sont cultivés
sur des sur des gouttières on a mis à la
fin d'hiver début du printemps
c'est pain de substrats dans lequel on a
planté un tous nos pieds de fraises la
clientèle ainsi que les fraises sont au
rendez vous le plein non j'en profite
enfin on en profite ma femme imprévu de
courtier ou un dépôt le but c'est que
chacun une barque est pleine et ramène
chez soi donc je pense qu'on finira
peut-être 6,7 kg la cueillette va
pouvoir durer tout l'été les fraises de
saison jusqu'en juillet et les
remontantes pourront être cueillies
jusqu'en octobre
vendredi 4 juin c'était la finale de koh
lanta les armes secrètes c'est
finalement un maxine qui a gagné
laventure et dans cette saison 2021
un minois étaient en lice il s'agit de
thomas qui est avec tout ce soir dont
sort thomas bonsoir vous êtes sorti lors
du onzième épisode de suite à votre
élimination au conseil alors avec le
recul est ce que vous êtes satisfait de
votre parcours bon on peut que se dise
pas qu'on appelait 30 jours sur 35 ans
près il reste cinq jours d' aventure
donc je suis satisfait mais j'ai un
petit coup de mer oui on a vu que vous
étiez très fatigué la fin de votre
aventure
est ce que ce sont les épreuves et est
le manque de nourriture qui vous ont
amené à un tel état tig
c'est le monde le monde de nourriture
pardon qui m'a emmené à ça j'ai perdu 4
pratiquement 14 kg
donc moi je suis un gros gabarit qui a
l'habitude de beaucoup faire du sport
que beaucoup manger donc bah
inconsciemment obligé perdu plus vite
que les autres et donc mon corps il a
été au delà de ce qu'il pouvait donner
c'était compliqué c'était dur pour vous
cette aventure ouais c'est dur on n'est
jamais préparé pour un faire un koh
lanta donc je m'étais préparé
psychologiquement et physiquement mais
on n'est jamais prêt à faire on s'attend
jamais à vivre dans le dur autant donc
donc voilà non tout s'est bien passé
pour moi après juste la fin est un petit
peu triste mais bon mon corps il pouvait
pas aller plus loin donc j'étais drôle
et si vous deviez refaire l'aventuré ce
que vous changeriez quelque chose je
devais enfin de change rien du tout
parce que j'ai été moi même j'ai
rencontré des très belles personnes
je suis restée moi j'ai avec mon
caractère comme on a pu voir avec une
fort caractère donc sont même somme des
tests et voilà donc maintenant je
recommencerai la voiture je vous ferai
la même chose
vous disiez sans vous aime sans vous
déteste durant l' aventure vous avez eu
quelques mots durs avec faire pas
candidat pendant le programme
on vous a beaucoup d'émigrés sur les
réseaux sociaux comment vous l'avez vécu
toutes ces critiques
franchement je regarde pas les je fais
pas trop attention à tout ça en fait je
regarde les réseaux sociaux puisque
c'est un venu à point travail mais à
côté de ça je paie pas du tout attention
moi parce que j'en pense de moi ou pas
parce que je sais que je savais qu'en
venant dans une émission comme ça on
pouvait pas plaire à tout le monde donc
il ya des gentils qu'ils m'adorent il ya
des gens qui m'aiment moins ça veut
partir ou pas de la vie on peut pas
plaire à tout le monde
après je savais c'est loi d'être
médiatisé donc c'est pas grave c'est
comme ça et j'imagine que tous les
moments passés sur cette île n'ont pas
été tous filmés est ce que vous auriez
peut-être une anecdote à nous dire que
les spectateurs de télé 78 ouais je peux
dire une anecdote c'est que avant la
réunification pendant qu'on gagnait tous
les conforts mans gagné avec l'équipe
jaune ont gagné pas mal de fois et on
s'est même permis de faire une pétanque
avec des noix de coco et béria mais
mathieu donc on a fait les olympiades de
nos olympiens donc c'était un petit
moment sympathique on a fait une
pétanque et un petit bowling donc voila
c'était on essayait de passer le temps
et on a bien rigolé et qu'est ce qu'elle
est aventure koh lanta vous a apporté
peut-être au quotidien l' aventure koh
lanta au quotidien ma portée le fait de
ne plus me prendre trop la tête pour des
choses superficielles et que on peut
vivre tellement bien sans avoir tout ce
qui est du paraître le match quoi donc
à l'heure actuelle je veux une vie
simple avec beaucoup de soleil parce que
bon bah j'aime le soleil donc
donc voila mais non il faut s'entourer
des bonnes personnes et rester soi même
et profiter de chaque instant puisque la
vie elle est courte
est ce que vous aimeriez peut-être
refaire une saison
les all stars par exemple ou alors
peut-être un programme différent mais
dans la survie moi je suis ouvert à
toute proposition maintenant c'est sûr
que l'idéal serait de refaire un
all-star m'affronter à recompter les
meilleurs après je dis pas je suis
meilleur que j'ai été à des milliards de
ma saison
la preuve j'ai été éliminé bien avant la
fin mai mais oui mais j'aimerais bien
retenter pourquoi pas si l'occasion se
présente à moi avant de refaire un koh
lanta avec plusieurs
merci beaucoup thomas d'avoir été notre
arrivée c'est très gentil merci à vous
[Musique]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose une idée de sortie pour ce week
end la fête annuelle de la bei happy
days revient pour une nouvelle édition
cette année la ferme pédagogique de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines propose plusieurs animations
gratuites de 10h30 à 17h samedi 19 juin
les visiteurs pourront participer à
l'extraction suivie d'une dégustation de
miel des expositions ainsi que des
ateliers pédagogiques feront partie du
programme
le but sensibiliser le public au rôle de
l'abeille et l'émission continue avec
eléonore pour parler de l'actualité
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week-end
merci de l'avoir suivi une très belle
soirée un très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et hop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]